[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christmas music back now at 7 30 on cbs
mornings thanksgiving of course it's
just two days away but many people are
already decking the halls for christmas
and most americans yes most americans
will get a christmas tree it is not a
christmas celebration without one three
out of four households
will go the tree route but this year it
may be more difficult to find a real or
an artificial tree as our nikki batiste
found out she's here with a look at
what's behind the christmas tree
shortage what is going on there's a lot
going on good morning everyone around 94
million americans celebrate the holiday
season with a christmas tree but this
year as a shortage looms those who wait
to shop or cut one down may find
themselves
tremendously out of luck
[Music]
for nearly 30 years the vanderwaalk farm
and winery in menden massachusetts has
been a destination for families
searching for the perfect christmas tree
but this year it will be quiet here
casey vanderwalk is the farm's owner
would you say there's a cut your own
christmas tree crisis this year
there is
last christmas during the height of the
pandemic the demand for a real tree was
higher than normal and vander valk
oversold cutting into this year's supply
there are not enough trees to actually
open
so you're closed for this season with
clothes for the season so how many trees
do you have on your plant we have 10 000
trees in the field right now wow
but the majority of them aren't the
right height yet it takes between 7 and
15 years for the trees to grow tall
enough to sell
yeah so that tree is 5 years old five
years exactly farmers across the country
are dealing with shortages for the same
reason vanderwalk is coupled with
excessive rain when we go through the
fields that all the small trees have
died because
they just sat and the roots just sat in
the water and just
you know couldn't dry out to grow are
you worried about climate change impact
on your business in years to come oh
absolutely because you know we've had a
lot more rain lately there are around 15
000 christmas tree farms in the u.s and
each year americans purchase
approximately 25 to 30 million real
christmas trees how would you describe
how a christmas tree
symbolizes
christmas and the holidays
that's hard it's definitely
it it symbolizes family
and that's
and that's what
you got me messed up yeah
this year there's also an artificial
tree shortage due to supply chain issues
about 85 percent of americans who
celebrate christmas put up an artificial
tree
this isn't the year to procrastinate it
is not for sure matt carman is the
founder and ceo of balsam hill a popular
artificial tree company what is going on
with the supply chain that makes it so
difficult now to get a tree what we're
seeing this year is that american
consumers are buying more than ever
before of big durable items things like
couches exercise equipment artificial
christmas trees and so we're trying to
bring in more products into the country
than our ports are designed to handle
and so everything's getting delayed
harman told us he's now paying about 300
percent more to bring his artificial
trees to the u.s from asia where they're
produced and that cost is being passed
on to consumers they've had to increase
prices this year about 20 percent
as for vander valk his family's homemade
wine business and last year sales will
keep them afloat but being closed for
the christmas season for the first time
in nearly three decades is still hard to
accept
i have to say just being here and seeing
it empty knowing it will stay empty this
year it's sad it is sad
don't do that you're going to make me
cry oh sorry it's sad it's
you can feel the joy that sort of
permeates through your property and your
business so it's hard to imagine we
definitely enjoy doing it
vanderwalk also purchases extra large
trees from a wholesaler in north
carolina to sell in addition to his own
cut your trees he said that farmer is
also facing a shortage vanderwalk says
they plan to be open next year but
depending on his trees they may need to
shorten their selling season i love him
i love his hat i love the emotion
underneath what he does he clearly finds
it meaningful uh and trees really matter
for households i would say you know you
know if you go the artificial route
that's fine it's a personal decision but
i think nothing smells like a real
christmas tree in the house right about
that do any of you have your tree yet oh
we already have ours up you do yeah the
wife put it up early we do too it wasn't
my doing i wanted to do it last weekend
i was overwhelmed thanksgiving you guys
have it up already yeah well slow it's
up it's slowly getting decorated because
bo is helping and he's 18 months when
you when you throw that thing out in
january it's going to be so dry it's
going to touch the door frame all the
needles are going to fall off it's going
to be you with the vacuum like this
casey the farmer says buy your tree as
soon as possible if you want one but to
help it last put it outside in a bucket
of water in the shade and then bring it
in the ceo of balsam hill says if you
want an artificial tree you better order
it by thanksgiving he says he wouldn't
wait much longer than that i felt for
casey we're just talking about trees
it's like okay we'll get one we won't
get one but that's his life's work that
he clearly cares about and it's a lot of
work and you can imagine all the
families feeling that beautiful land of
buying trees joy and we let you come to
the table even with that very bad pun
tremendously sure
i'm tremendously out of luck vlad was
cheering you on i love you
well done
thank you nikki thank you